この新居に来てからじゃんと1か月ぐらい型投資いるんですけども
外を見てくれ地ツアーん
カーテンがまだないんだ
あのはない事じゃない笑い事じゃないからねそりゃも悠々ながいいは関係ないとですね
結構目の前に立ってことがあるんで簡単に向こうの人から俺の私生活が全部丸見えな
状態です俺が何しても全部わかる俺食べてるものをこの大きなクマとして俺がカメラに
向かって大声でしゃべってるような光景針となんかどう
うぜみたいな感じで生活を作るんですけども今回もなんとカーテンをねちょっと
いただいたということでね本当に本当に to school
今一番欲しいモンスターて4 p 4 p 一方デイリーますあぁそれ
終わってるなぁ金がトップ4かっていうのは後々話していくからとりあえずですね
こちらの間でネイビーですねさっそく釣れんつけてみましょう
やっと俺も生活に逃げ出したら出てくるってわけですむしろよく今までカーテンだして
俺がここにやって来たと思ってる
今日美穂
もうここは山へ人間っぽいぞ入会フォンとなんか大字三宅に仕上げてるなぁと思ったら
星
大ちょっとを破ったこのホイヤー heuer こんな感じだ
いやー過程がないってまいりどちらにせよ廃棄時の方なんですけど割と薄い感じなん
ですけどもしっかりしてて丈夫ですはいと呼びや1か月の年月を超えてようやくお出汁
のいいにもカーテンがつきましたらどちらフィットでこと言うカーテンでございます定
7万人がすごいかっていうのをまず説明しなかったから今からをしようと思う
カーテンっていうのはやっぱり基本的にはこのなの状態で楽しみっていうのは普通だと
思うんですけどもこのピットレックは人はずっ違いましてですね貼ってはがせる今まで
にない新しいカーテンでございますカーテンを自分好みにカスタマイズしたいコーン
ながらのカーテンがあったらいいのにそんな希望を叶えてくれる素晴らしい商品で
ございますこういう記事を挟ん
にで切って例えば好きな形とかにしてここに貼ったりすることもできます他にもこれ
ピットでこのですね
カーテンにつけるようどんどんなどもございますちょっと上げてみましょう
はい開けていましたこういう3色の布が入っておりますマカロンにはこういう3色が
入っておりますまあこの基準マンハサミで切ったりして火な形をつくってそれを
マーカーてに
あっと腫れたりいろんな形を切ってカラフルなカーテンを作ったりすることも可能で
ございます
実際にですねこの布を切ってこういう感じでですね
これは月と犬です犬だからな好きと n とかこういうで自分の好きな形で布をカット
して裏に専用のテープを張ってカーテンに貼ることもできます配線用のテープをつけて
これだけで
ってに和室がないんですけどカーテンにはくっつきますまあカーテンにいるの模様が
作れるという感じでございます全然貼るだけで関連のイメージが変わりますベッドで
構成
用のシールがあってこれを張ってると付入れますスマホに貼ってみますこれでくっつい
たら凄いぜ
わー結構丈夫なんで落ちる感じがあって
こいつは便利なという感じですねまぁいろんなような挑んでこういう奴をくっつけて
自分の好きなカーテンにできます型レーダーののとかを張っていく美しいカーテン
かわいいカーテンを作るの多いんですけれども俺の使い方
人は違うぜ英語と日本語を書いたプリントを用意します学校で習ってる英語と日本語で
いいです
あったりと
入ったで出来るわけなんて何度も使えるわけなんですよまあ英語の勉強しようってね
犬バンッ
絹犬カー意味どれかなぁ
アドックだオイリーなドッグパロパロがー
今日は nerf オーレボールボール4れそうだ
パープルプレイヤー市内には像を塗り替えチディちゃんといえば英語の良い会話でき
ますじゃ state 無音 ftse パーネを勝ち取ることができる状態のこと
覚えておきましたこれでます卒中パーカリスナー絶景や増車素晴らしい信じられないと
いう意味がエヴァ回送
nst tx sop バーストすぐ使えるのでぜひこれも覚えましょうね一緒に
っていうねコーデチーク系というか勉強などにを微カーデを使えるということがわかり
ますね
幅てるんで何台も繰り返し使えます実はですね他の部屋にもこちらのかなってつけたん
ですけどまぁ僕はよくねやっぱり悠遊カードをやるじゃんカーブゲームで見てる
しています
あの8も落ちないくらいの強さになってますよく使う汎用カードとかレアカードとかね
バシバシと張ってくるわけですが
はレゾネがちで見やすいからその普通に使えますまずもみんなの趣味にあったことに
激高何関連が使えることもあるかもしれないんですよパズルみたいなゲームを楽しめる
と僕は考えました
エプコがこちらですね鵜匠のユーチューバーの
麺とね胴体そして足を準備しましたこういうので
アタマン体操するんだぜ僕はちょっと作ってみましょう
中田者数なかなか思い通りにいかないもんだな
うーんちょっとあんまりうまくいかなかったん
はけどねぇ
だいたいみんな人間っぽいパズルみたいな楽しみ方もできるっていう夢カーテンで最低
でそちらのピットでこのカーテンの紹介でございました
国税がこんだけ楽しめたんで行った中でこういうのを考える人とかもっと面白いことが
できるんじゃねーかーと思います中根カーテンでね遊ぶって発想
至らないと思うのでうわぁ人のような家庭
えん家に届いたという事でとても満足しています皆さんもデヴィッドゲッコー3子さえ
貼れば色とも中に帰るそうなっても楽しめる勝手だと思うので是非フィットでこの
カーテン使ってみてはいかがでしょうか
じゃあ